愛国心についての動画に質問が来ていたので校調に答えていただきたいと思いますと。先生は冤罪をかけられ、しかも人質法によって不闘に拘束され続け、地方行政など国家期間から多大な被害をったと推いたします。それにも関わらずなぜ変わらぬ愛国心を抱いておられるのでしょうか?
愛国心というのは国家機関に対する愛じゃないわね。国に対する愛だから。
むしろ国民に対する愛やで。だから愛国が
あればあのバカどもをおっ払らうことが
できるじゃん。民主主義っていうのはそう
いう風やからね。ダメなやつを権力の座
から通報することができるのが民主主義な
んだからああいうダメ[音楽]な完僚に
しろ政治家はねみんなで選んだんだから
しょうがないよね。だけど本当はよく
分かってあいうダメな政治家というのは
おっ払らわんといかんわな。
司法とかあと裁判所とかにも不闘の扱いを受けたっていうことなんですけど、それでもその愛国心っていうのはこうやっぱもう別物のっていうことなんですかね。
[音楽]
それ愛国心っていうのはね、本能としてあるんだね。だから愛国心というのは消えないんよ。自分の中から。
校長の愛国心っていうのは例えばなんかどういう時に感じるとかありますか?
国を守るということ。例えばね、ヨのレースやるやろ。
シングルハンドレース言って
サンフランシスコから沖縄までのレース
やったんやりでレースてな厳しいんよね。
ヨだからのんびりしとろやろう言うて
みんな思っとるけどとんでもない顔を死ん
で頑張っとるわけやな。というのはゴール
した時1秒負けたらもうダメな[音楽]ん
だからスポーツは勝つことが目的だから
ともかく1秒を受けって頑張らんといかん
でその時にあもう限度があるもんでな
頑張るにも最初はもう俺のためにと思っ
てるわけ俺が優勝して名をあげるんだと
いうのが頑張る理由やそれはまあええかと
いうもうこんなに辛いんやったらもう
頑張るのやめて少し楽しようかなと
思い出すんやでその時にね今度[音楽]は
家族のためにとか周りの自分の仲間のため
にという風に思うんや。それやったら
頑張れるやろ。で、また少し頑張るんや。
で、それもね、ダメになってくるんや。
こんなに辛いんやったら、まあ、家族は
我慢してもらおう。仲間も我慢して
もらおうということになる。そうするとね
、次にスポンサーのためにと思うわ。これ
だけの金を出してくれて、これだけ色々
優遇してもらって、負けたではすまんなと
思う。仮があるわけやからね。そのために
頑張ろうと思うわ。そのうちにそれもまあ
ええかっていうことになってくるんよ。2
位でも許してもらおうと思うことね。そし
たらね、今度は国のために頑張ろうと思う
[音楽]んや。外人がおるもんでね。
あんなもんに負けたら国の恥やかけ
たレースやからね。だから国のために
頑張るぞと思うわ。愛国なん。最後は愛国
が頑張らせてくれる。そ僕の周りの経営者
の方とかでもなんか愛国のために
るっていう[音楽]方が優秀な方が多い。
そうやろね。
本能にあるから、その本能はなくならんからね。
[音楽]
もう優れたリーダーっていうのはもう愛国心が強い。本能が強いから愛国心が強いっていうのは当たり前なんですかね。
うん。そうなんけどね、こういう例があるんよ。
[音楽]
イギリスでね、ナポレオン時代の感染の長であれが国の元やからね。イギリスなんか島国やもんで回線で負けたらもう国が潰れるんや。
その時に戦えば必ず勝つ感と戦えば必ず負ける館長とるわけよ。そういう国の石門でそのそれを調べるわけだ。イギリスはな。ああいう国やから。
うん。
そうすると戦えば必ず勝つ館長というのは尊敬される館長やって。
[音楽]
で、戦えば必ず負ける館長っていうのは尊敬されない館長やって。今度はね、どうしたら尊敬されるかということを調べとるわけよ。
なん[音楽]とね、バツが公平なこと。
日本はシが与えれば尊敬されると思っとる
じゃん。教育なんかそうやね。褒めての
せっていうのは。だけど実際はバツが公平
なことやってからバツを公平にするのは
非常に難しいわけよ。相手の悪いとこが
きっちり[音楽]分からんといかん。それ
もどれぐらい悪いかということが分からん
といかんからそれができる人っていう
[音楽]のは人格ない。
どういう人がそれができる人だと思いますか?
強い人やん。弱い人はそれができへんじゃない?
本能が強い人。
本能が強い人な。だからイギリスは教育においても遠慮釈ないよね。チャーがな、このままでは何年も口にイギリスは潰れるという状態になってへん。イギリス病って言うんや。で、その時にさは教育だって見抜いたわけ。教育の何が悪いかと言うと愛国心の否定が悪いって言うんや。
で、愛国心の否定をする教育をやってんの
は左翼だから左翼を教育会から追放すれば
技術は立ち直る。実際にそれはやるんや。
そういうとこはすごいんよね。やったら
ばイギスは立ち直ったんやから愛国教育を
やればええて[音楽]いうこと。
え、校長のよくおっしゃる話で、あの、女性政治家で高一さんに対しては結構定的じゃないですか?
一方で、ま、立憲民主党とかの野党っぽい議員さんは女性の方多かったりするじゃないですか。両者の違いって何なんですか?
[音楽]
あれはね、高石さんは完璧な保守やないか。身についとるんよ。だけど野党になる女の子、女の子まと怒られるな。女性はなんかこう女の弱さを武器にしとるやん。
うん。うん。だからこう女性のためにとか
なんとか言い出すやん、すぐに。あれが
ためなとこない。女性のために議員がおる
わけやないやろ。日本全体のためにおるの
に。女性子供っていうのが被害者なんだ
からどうのこ弱者の理論やろ。殺されるが
あの理論なんや。だからダメな。うまく
いかんのや。前よく言ってやった
フェニズム。フェミニズムをやる人は
みんなイチだよ。なぜならばフェニズムの
元[音楽]どっからあれが出てきたんや。
ボールの第2のせ、哲学だね。だから
ボブボRの第2のせを呼んでみっぺン。
1番最初が間違えとるんだ。[音楽]だ
から全体が間違ると思ったらええんだ。
そういう間違いで行動を起こしたって日祖
と一緒や。1番最初何が書いてある?
その男とは何か、女とは何か、男らしさとは何か、女らしとはなんかが書いてあるんやけど、それはもうとんでもないことを書いてあるわけ。理性論であってね、本の論じゃないんよ。
だから間違えない。